Speaker 1: Let's go to Grant from Iowa
City. Grant, welcome to the program.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. So I know you get
a lot of criticism and stuff, obviously,
from people. You are on the right side of.
Speaker 1: You and the left on the.
Speaker 5: Spectrum. And what get a lefty that is
going to say so far when you get criticism from
people left of you, from me personally, I like it
just gives me like a ton of anxiety. I get nervous
about it because I am afraid of being perceived
as like this, you know, negative, whatever.
Speaker 1: A negative, Nancy, is that
I just feel like we're not supposed to
use negative Nancy anymore.
Speaker 5: I'm not sure.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know either.
Speaker 5: But even stuff like that,
I guess I like hearing that. I would
be like, oh gosh, like, I know,
please don't think I'm a bad person. You know.
Speaker 1: I ate an egg. Please don't kill me.
Speaker 5: Yeah. So I guess how do you
kind of personally handle, you know,
getting criticism from people left of you who
would say, you know, you're either you're a
horrible person for what you believe or whatever.
As for me, just kind of naturally wanting to live
at peace of like everybody is just like, yeah, I
don't know, it it really bends me out of shape.
Speaker 1: Well, here's the thing.
A lot of this stuff in person
would not become what it is when you're leaving
someone a voicemail or leaving a comment on their
videos. People are just, by their nature, much
more confrontational online. And so I see, you
know, these people who attacked me from the left,
but we agree on like 95% of stuff. I don't get too
bent out of shape about it, quite frankly. I don't
really pay much attention to any of it. I just
kind of do my thing and and try to focus on what
I'm doing and learn and read as much as I can and
modify my views when I feel that the facts point
me in in a new direction and I try to screen out
as much of the noise as possible left and right.
Speaker 5: Right? Right. I'm sure it's absolutely
necessary for you as well. Like,
you know, having such a, you know,
a lot of encounters with so many people. I could
not do it. You do? Definitely won't say that much.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Speaker 5: But yeah,
I know. I was just wondering. And has it
gotten easier for you? Like as you get older to
just like, is it easier to screen out the negative
noise? Absolutely not taking it so seriously.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Without a doubt. Yeah,
no doubt about it. I mean, at the beginning,
it was like one negative comment, which was,
by the way, we only would get one comment a
day and it was like a really big deal.
But yeah, it definitely becomes easier.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm just curious
because it's like I'm thinking, like,
I'm way behind on this stuff because I'm almost
26 now and I'm like, I feel like I get bent out
of shape as if I'm a seven year old or something.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I think part of it is one
of the things is really understanding that for a
lot of these people that are so willing and eager
to criticize others, they probably don't feel
that great about themselves. And often attacks
on others are more a reflection of the attackers
either low self-esteem or trials or tribulations.
And once I started thinking that like, wow,
this person must really have some horrible stuff
going on to be spending an hour on the Internet,
leaving me a hundred negative comments. I kind of
feel bad for them more than anything else.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah, I started my question wasn't
a political one or whatever.
Speaker 1: No, that's okay.
Do you want a trivia question before you go?
Speaker 5: Oh, gosh. You can try. I'm going to
totally botch it because I'm quite nervous.
Speaker 1: But okay, here we.
Speaker 4: Can go for it, I.
Speaker 1: Guess. What is the
typical name for a dried plum when you buy it as
a dried fruit? What do they call it? Dried plum.
Speaker 5: A prune.
Speaker 1: You're
absolutely correct.
Speaker 5: Okay.
Absolutely correct. You did it on purpose.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend. Thank you
for the call. I appreciate it. Thanks, David.
All right. Take care. There's Grant from Iowa
City. Really excellent, excellent execution there
on the on the trivia trivia question that could
have gone bad. It could have gone very bad. And
thankfully, it did not. Let's go to somewhere
from Metro. Somewhere I can't see it's met. Where
are you calling from? Samarra. Samira left. Okay.
Samira apparently did not want to be on. That's
that's interesting. Let's go to instead Garrett
from Chicago. Garrett, welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Hello, Mr. David. The Pac-Man, sir.
Speaker 1: Welcome. Thank you.
Speaker 4: My question is about.
Like the popularity of candidates when affecting
other people that are running in the same
election. I worded that poorly. Just to give you
an example. In Georgia, Brian Kemp is currently
leading six or seven points in most of the polls.
Speaker 5: Okay.
Speaker 4: And he's a Republican, obviously,
whereas Warnock is currently up anywhere from
3 to 5.
Speaker
1: What I saw, Warnock is up 1.3.
Speaker 4: 1.3. Okay. Well,
I'm just I have FiveThirtyEight pulled out
the most recent polls, but. Yeah, so, uh.
My question is, will the will the popularity
of Warnock or the end of Warnock or Kemp affect
the. Do you think it'll affect the turnout
of the other side? Like, do you think Kemp's
popularity will improve Walker's chances,
or do you think Warnock chant or Warnock's
popularity will improve? Stacey Abrams chances.
Speaker 1: Oh, I that is so specific. I have
no idea. Listen, turnout in midterms, predicting
turnout in midterms is very fraught and difficult.
And every election cycle, it's, oh, turnout,
it's going to win it for this person or that
person. And it's so difficult to predict.
And your question is even more specific,
which is whatever base level of turnout is to
be expected. Will one candidate's popularity
bouie or sink another canard? I just have
no idea. I think all we can do right now,
we're a month out. It's basically four and a half
weeks or something until the election roughly is.
Make sure you're registered. Make sure you know
where to vote and make sure to vote. That said,
and I think all of these calculations, they're
interesting questions. We're we're going to know
in retrospect, only once we get exit poll data.
I don't know. We've just really got to make sure
not to lose any of these winnable races.
Speaker 4: Okay. Thank you very much,
Mr. David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Do you want a
trivia question before you go?
Speaker 4: Of course.
Speaker 1: What's the most expensive
spice by weight? And when we say spice,
we're talking about cooking. What's
the most expensive spice by weight?
Speaker 4: So not the spice from doon?
No, no, no, no. Oh, geez. Probably. Uh.
Speaker 5: Um.
Speaker 4: I'm going to say I can only name,
like, three spices. I'm going to say time.
Speaker 1: No, no. Time is cheap. Oh,
my God. It's almost a weed. It's almost
invasive. The answer is saffron. It's saffron.
Speaker 4: Oh, yes, of course. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right. Very
good. Thank you for the call.
Speaker 4: Thank you, sir.
Speaker 1: All right. I really appreciate
everybody who called in and spoke to me.
I even appreciate people who called in and
didn't speak to me. The people who didn't
call in. I'm not so big on you folks, but.
No, in all seriousness, we will take calls
again. We're going to take a quick break and we
will be back with more show right after this.